sometimes it's easy for us to forget the
Last Guardian is even being made but
apparently it's easy for publisher Sony
as well as yesterday it emerged The Last
Guardian trademark has been abandoned
according to its status page on the
united states patent and trademark
office Sony Computer Entertainment
America's trademarks The Last Guardian
has not been renewed the abandonment
occurred because no statement of use or
extension request was filed after a
notice of allowance was issued on
january fifteenth does this mean it's
finally over for Sony's long-delayed
flagship adventure game well a Sony
spokesman has confirmed to gamespot that
the Last Guardian is still in
development leading us to believe that
after six years since it was announced
it's possible someone simply forgot to
renew that trademark in December last
year Game Director Fumito Vader said The
Last Guardian was moving forward under
completely new conditions without giving
specifics it was possible a widow was
referring to the game transitioning from
PlayStation 3 2 PlayStation 4 as it was
initially announced back in 2009 as a
ps3 title sony has dodged questions
about platforms ever since so is this
game ever going to materialize or are we
looking at another Duke Nukem Forever
also presumably that trademark is now up
for grabs so if anyone's making a flappy
Guardians mobile game out there perhaps
you could snap it up just an idea
you